[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداث وتتفاعل البدايه من
واشنطن حيث افاده وثيقه داخليه اليوم ان
نحو 50 بالمئه من موظفين تويتر سيتاثرون
بعمليه التسريح الجاريه حاليا في الشركه
الان الى اسلام اباد وهذه الصور المباشره
حيث تعيش العاصمه الباكستانيه على وقع
توتر متصاعد مع اتهام عمران خان برئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني شهباز شريف بالضروعي
في محاوله اغتياله
الى غزه
ومشهد يقول بعد غارات يقول فيها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انها استهدفت مجمعا
لتصنيع مكونات الصواريخ تحت الارض تابعا
لحركه حماس في مخيم المغازي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
جوجل
الخميس عمران خان يتهم رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني ووزير الداخليه وقائدا كبيرا
في المخابرات بالضلع في محاوله اغتياله
الحكومه تنفي وتلقي باللوم اعلى مسلح
باعتبارات دينيه
واحتجاجات في انحاء متفرقه من باكستان
[تصفيق]
في مقاله انه رد على اطلاق صواريخ من
القطاع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقصف موقعا
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه وحماس تصف
القصف بانهم امتداد للحرب المفتوحه على
الشعب
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال اثناء التصدي
لاعتداء مستوطنين على الاهالي في نابلس
في مؤثرا على تراجع ان روسيا في واحده من
اكثر المناطق المتنازع عليها في اوكرانيا
من مناطق في اقليم خرسان الجنوبيه
في مدينه خرسون بعد دقائق من اعلامه
الجيش الاوكراني يقول ان دفاعاته الجويه
اسقطت صاروخين روسيين من طراز كاليبر في
بيكو لايف واخرسون
كوريا الجنوبيه تعلن اطلاقا مقاتلات شبح
بعد رصد 180 طائره حربيه تابعه لبيونج
وتؤكد وجوزيه الطائرات الامريكيه المشاركه
في مناورات معها وفي جلسه لمجلس الامن
الدولي الولايات المتحده تتهم روسيا
والصين بتبرير معتبرتها انتهاكات متكرره
ترتكبها كوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم زياره المستشار
الالماني اولف شولدز لبجين وهو الاول من
بين قاده مجموعات السبعه الذي يزول الصين
منذ ظهور وبائينا
والاستطلاع رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال يقول
اين هو السؤال
برايكم في اي سياق تاتي زياره شمس لجين
جاءت الاجابه على النحو التالي قال لا نحو
52% ان هذه الزياره تفتح الباب نحو
التعاون صيني اوروبي بينما قال نحو 48% ان
الزياره تاتي في سياق الضغط على بيجين
لعدم دعم مصر
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا نتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
لوثيقه داخليه تويتر تسرح قرابه 50% من
موظفيها في انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الثلاثه قرروا قتلي هذا ما قاله
رئيس الوزراء باكستاني السابق عمران خان
للصحفيين
في اول ظهور علنيا له منذ نقله الى
المستشفى بعد محاوله اغتياله امس الخميس
من هم الثلاثه الضالعون في التخطيط
لمحاوله الاغتيال هم رئيس الوزراء الحالي
شباب شريف وزير الداخليه وقائد كبير في
الجيش والكلام طبعا
الحكومه تنفيذ وتلقي باللوم على مسلح
باعتبارات دينيه كما قالت
شراره الغضب وقد امتد لهيبها الى شوارع
باكستان
انظروا رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
تظاهروا تعبيرا عن تمديدهم بمحاوله اغتيال
زعيمهم
مظاهرات شملت عده مدن وتخللتها اشتباكات
مع الشرطه
اما خان وبعد تلقيه العلاج بعد اصابته
برصاصه في رجله فقد دعا انصاره لمواصله
الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه التي وصفها
بالمستورده وجدد اتهام حزبه لرئيس الحكومه
ووزير الداخليه
ولمسؤول في المخابرات بالتخطيط الاختياله
ساواصل مطالبه باجراء انتخابات عامه مبكره
بمجرد انتهاء فتره علاجه ومن هنا اناشد
الجنرال على باجوا قائد الجيش التدخل
لانقاذ باكستان فالدوله في طريقها الى
انهيار
في المقابل لمحه الحكومه الاحتمال تورط
عناصر دينيه متطرفه في محاوله اغتيال
عمران خان المعروف
بتصريحاته المتطرفه بحسب وزير الداخليه
بصفه وزير الداخليه ونشد قياده الحزب
مراجعه ترتيباتهم من امنيه ومستوى الحمايه
لمسيراتهم كانت هناك تهديدات امنيه وقد
تجاهلوها واذا تجاهلوها مره ثانيه فاخشى
ان يتكرر الاعتداء عليهم
وبينما ساعه عمران خان الناجي من محاوله
اغتيال للاستفاده من الموقف
كرر التحالف الحزبي الحاكم في باكستان
رفضه الخضوع لمطلب رئيس الوزراء السابق
الداعي الى تنظيم الانتخابات عامه مبكرا
تستمر اذا حاله الاستقطاب
السياسيه في باكستان ضمن صراع على السلطه
يخشى ان يجعل الساحه السياسيه وحتى
الجماهيريه مفتوحه على كثير من
السيناريوهات عبد الرحمن مطار الجزيره
انا قد رفض الجيش والباكستاني اتهمته رئيس
الحكومه المقال ال عمران خان لاضابه في
جهاز المخابرات برتبه جنرال بالتورط في
محاوله اغتياله ووصف بيان العسكريه في
جهاز المخابرات فيصل نصير اتهمه بالباطل
او وصفه بالاحرى بالباطل ودعى البيان
الحكومه لاجراء تحقيق موسع في محاوله
الاعتداء على عمران خان كما حضر بيان
الجيش من مغبه التعرض لاين من ضباط
معنى معنى الان من اسلام اباد عيسى نقوي
الاعلامي والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك
على اي اساس جاء اتهام عمران خان لهؤلاء
الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
يقول ان لديه
مصادره الخاصه فقد كان رئيسا وزراء لهذا
البلد ولديه من ما يزالون يعملون في
الاستخبارات وهم الذين نقلوا اليه هذه
المعلومات
والان عمران خان يمكنه ان يقدم تفاصيل
لكنها اتهامات خطيره
ولابد انكم ايضا نوع رد ردوا الفعل التي
جاءت من العسكريين
الباكستانيين هذه اتهامات غير مسبوقه
في تاريخ باكستان كان هناك رئيس وزراء اخر
شريك الذي وجه اتهامات الى مسؤولين كبار
في القوات المسلحه في 2020
لندن وذلك كان خلاف وجوده في لندن اذا
السياسيون
الذين يكلمون
الشعب وهم في سريري مرض في مستشفى هذا امر
غير مسبوق ولكن لا يبدو كلام السيد عمران
خان وكانه مجازفه لانه يذكر اشخاص بالاسم
في حين لم يجري تحقيق بعد ولا توجد
بالطبيعه الحال في الوقت الحالي محاكمه
عادله تبين المعطيات
ربي يخليك
الكثير من الغموض حتى
لو راينا ما حدث بعد هذا الحادث خلال قرب
من قريبا من وزير عباده الاول المعلومات
لم تذكر
ولم يتم تسجيلها
ضد المهاجمين
ومن الواضح ان هناك من يقول انهما كان
مهاجمين وحدهما اطلق النار من اتجاهين
مختلفين عن يمينه عن يساره ثم كذلك من جهه
اخرى هذه التحقيقات ينبغي ان تتم لان هذا
النوع من الاتهامات لا يمكن اثباته بهذه
السهوله لكن ما هي الاثباتات التي لدى
عمران خان ليدعم بها ادعاء تهامه ربما ان
هناك
همم المساومه
لكي يحصل على نوع من
الاجواء مواتيه له
السياسي اصبح اكثر صعوبه بمرور الزمن لديه
مطالب ايضا
يطالب بانتخابات مبكرا هو يحاول
استخدام جميع خياراته
وهذا لم يحدث من قبل كما قلت ان ال- ال-
النزاعات السياسيه تبدو شرسه الان هناك
غضب
وبشكل الماء لسوء الحظ فانا ليست فقط
الاحزاب السياسيه
اخذ موقفا وهاجم ايضا القوات المسلحه
من اسلام الينا ايضا من اسلام اباد طاهر
نعيم الكاتب حلل همم السياسي همم سيد نعيم
اهلا وسهلا بك همم السلطات سارعت للنفي
كوزار الداخليه وكشيش على اي اساس ايضا
جاء هذا النفي
يقوم على انه من السابق لاوانه ان يتم
استخراج ذلك كما قال سيد عيسى هناك
اول همم معلومات عن الحادث لم يتم التاكد
منها
في ولايه بنجاب
وحزب عمران خان
وهناك في حزب موالي او متحالف مع حزب
انصاف
وعمران خان حزبه هو الغاضب
وعليهم ان يسجلوا المعلومات
امنيه
التي كان من المفروض ان توفر الامن همم
عمران خان رئيس الوزراء السابق
باربي
الخطه الامنيه
للحزب نفسه فيها ثغرات لانه وزاره
الداخليه في ولايه بونجاب
تقول ان الحزب لا ينبغي ان يخرج
بهذه الطريقه وينبغي ان يكون مرتديا سترات
واقيه همم من الرصاص
كذلك ينبغي تنسيق النواحي الامنيه بطريقه
تمنع مثل هذه المحاولات
ومن قبل همم حراس الامن في باكستان لدينا
ايه حكم في جيرالي وهناك جهاد امنيه
مختلفه
وهناك اعمال
ارهابيه
طالما طالما استشهد بضيفنا السابق عيسى
قوي سيد عيسى قال عمران خان كان رئيس
وزراء وما زال لديه من يمكن ان يثق بهم في
جهاز الجيش وفي جهاز الامن والمخابرات
وهذه المعلومات مستنيده الى ناس ثقات كيف
يمكن همم توضيح هذه النقطه
هو يثق في الجهات معينه لكن عندما
تمت مهاجمته كانت الحكومه
الحكومه الولايه او المحافظه هي التي
ينبغي ان توفر له الامن لان حزب عمران خان
هو من الاحزاب القليله
المواليه لطالبان ولم يكن
لديها اي تهديد من اي جهات ارهابيه
اذا لم يكن متاهبا
وكان الهجوم عليه سهلا في وسط ولايه
محافظه بنجاب وفي بلد مثل
باكستان ينبغي ان يكون الامن مشددا
لتنظيم مسيرات كبيره
[موسيقى]
مكونات الصواريخ تحت الارض تابعه لحركه
حماس في مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع غزه وقال
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاحتلال ان القصه جاء
ردا على اطلاق قضاء فسارقيه من غزه مساء
امس الخميس واضاف ان المجمع الذي تم
استهدافه يضم ايضا مبنى لانتاج المواد
الكيميائيه المخصصه لانتاج المحركات
الصاروخيه من جهتها قالت كتائب القسام
الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس ان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف موقع الكتيبه الثالثه
عشره على مدخل مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه
واضافت الكتاب في اول تعقيب لها على
الغارات الاسرائيليه فجر اليوم ان
مضاداتها الارضيه تصدت للطائرات
الاسرائيليه
وفي ردود الفعل وصفت حركه حماس القذف
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه بانه عدوان سافر
وامتداد للحرب المفتوحه على الشعب
الفلسطيني الناطق باسم الحركه حازم قاسم
قال في بيان انما سماه الارهاب الصهيوني
لن يوقف ثوره الشعب الفلسطيني المتساعده
وفي الضفه الغربيه
جنوب نابلس وقال الاهالي ان مواجهات
اندلعت بين المستوطنين وجنود الاحتلال من
جهه وشبان القريه الذين حاولوا التصدي لهم
وقد اطلق جنود الاحتلال القنابل صوتيه
والغازه المسيله للدموع ما ادى الى اصابه
فلسطينيين بلغتناق واحتراق اشجار الزيتون
في القريه
مشهد التصعيد في الضفه والقطاع بمرحله قد
تكونوا اكثر تعقيدا مع فوزي تحالف اليمين
بزعامه نتنياهو في الانتخابات الاخيره هذا
التحالف تبوء فيه حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
موقع مهما بعد ان بات صاحب ثالث اكبر حصه
في مقاعد الكنيسه تتزايد والتساؤلات بشان
ابعاد هذا المتغير وبينما يراه البعض
تعبيرا عن التطرف والعنصريه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي مازال من غير الواضح فاذا كان
اتمار بن غفير احد ابرز قاده هذا الحزب
سيتمكن من الحصول على منصب منصب وزير
الامن الداخلي في الحكومه المقبله تقرير
ماجد عبد الهادي
حتى في المستوى السياسيه الاسرائيلي نفسه
هناك من يعرب الان عن قلق متزايد من صعود
للفاشيه اظهرت نتائج الانتخابات التشريعيه
التي انتهت للتو واسفلت عن فوزي حزب
الليكود بزعامه بنيامين نتنياهو ومعه قوى
اليمين الاشد تطرفنا باغلبيه مريحه من
مقاعد الكنيست في مقابل هزيمه حزب هناك
مستقبل الذي يتزعمه رئيس الوزراء الحاليد
ومعه حلفاؤه في الائتلاف الحكومي
صحيح ان بعضا من من استخدم كلمه الفاشيه
في وسط المتغيرات الجديده قد اضطر سريعا
الى التراجع عنها مكرهين تحت ضغط حساسيتها
التاريخيه المثيره لمواجع اليهود
لكنما فهمه الجميع هو ان الحديث يدور عن
اختراق والساعه حققته الحركه الكاهنيه وفي
مقدمتها حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه واجهته
الابرز اتمار بنت بحصوله على 14 مقعدا
برلمانيه ليصبح بذلك اكبر الاحزاب
الاسرائيليه وافرض نفسه قطبا بالغا
الاهميه في مفاوضات تشكيل الحكومه المقبله
والكهنيه بمعناها المتداول في اسرائيل
مصطلح ينسم التيارات الدينيه السياسيه
المتطرفه الى الحاخام ايركانا مؤسس حركه
كاخ التي ارتكب احد اعضائها ويدعى باروخ
جولد شتاين عام 94 من القرن الماضي مذبحه
مروعه اودت بحياه عشرات المصلين
الفلسطينيين داخل الحرم الابراهيمي في
مدينه الخليل
واستغلتها سلطات الاحتلال حين اذن باتخاذ
قرار باغلاق المسجد التاريخيه ثم بتقسيمه
فيما بعد زمانيا ومكانيا بين المسلمين
واليهود على نحو قهريا لا يزال قائما لا
بل صار يشكل منذ فرد نموذجا
واليمين على الاقل الى تكراره في الحرم
القدسي الشريف
وان يكن هدف تهويد المسجد الاقصى تمهيدا
لبناء ما يسمى الهيكله في مكانه هو بعض
مما يضعه حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه على راس
اولوياته فان السلوك قيادته واعضائه لم
يبقي معنا من معاني التطرف والعنصريه الا
وعمل على ترجمته واقعيه دون ما حرج
الذي هاجر والده من العراق الى فلسطين
يسكن في مستوطنه كريات اربعه وسط مدينه
الخليل ويطالب بضم الضفه الغربيه الى
اسرائيل وبترض فلسطين داخل ما لم يقروا
بيهوديه الدوله هو اعتدى ايضا ان يتصدر
عمليات اقتحام المستوطنين للحرم القدسي
الشريف ويقود على ابتداءاتهم على حي الشيخ
جراح ملوحا في بعض الاحيان بمسدسه كما انه
لم يتورع عن التصريح علنا بمباركه لجيش
الاحتلال بقتل الزميله شيرين ابو عاقل
يريد ان يتولى في الحكومه المقبله منصبه
وزير الامن الداخلي وفي تصوره انه سيتمكن
من فعل ما فشل فيه السابقه عبر منح جنود
الاحتلال حريه مطلقه في استهدافه من
يظنونه خطيرا من الفلسطينيين وتوفير حصانه
كامله لكل ضابط او جندي يقتل فلسطينيا
لكن ذلك على خطورته ليس الا احد بواع في
القلق الذي اثاره صعود بينك فير وثمه في
الاوساط السياسيه الاسرائيليه من يحذرون
الاناء من تدمير ما يصفون باسس
الديمقراطيه التي بنيت عليها الدوله لتحلى
محلها اسس الاستبداد الدينيه وتسود فكره
تفوق اليهود وتتفشل عنصريه على نحو المرعب
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فقط
باتت مقاطعه اخرسون تتصدر وعناوين المعارك
بعد حديث للقوات الاوكرانيه عن تقدم
المستمر يقابله حديث روسي عن تصدر لكل
الهجمات رويتان لا تنفيان وقوع اجراءات
اعاده تموضع الروسيه تطرح الاسئله بخصوص
مستقبل السيطره على هذه المقاطعه
تتسارع التطورات الميدانيه المتلاحقه خاصه
في الجبهه الجنوبيه في اوكرانيا خرسون
تتصدر المشهد وسطه غموض بشان مستقبل سيطره
عليها حيث يواصل الجيش الاوكراني الاعلان
عن احرازين نتائج ميدانيه اخرها السيطره
على قريتي مالا سيديمن
لروسيا اخبره هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه
لكنهم قالوا انهم تصدا لهم والحقوا خسائر
فادحه بقوتهم كما قالت السلطات المواليه
لموسكو في خرسون انها اعترضت مجموعه من
الصواريخ واسقطت ثمانيه طائره مسيره القوه
الروسيه بحسب المجلس الاقليمي بالمقاطعه
اوقفت عملها في المبنى الحكوميه الرئيسي
بالمدينه وتواصل تفكيك منشات ومعدات طبيه
كما اكدت مصادر محليه في المقاطعه ان عدد
القوات الروسيه في المدينه انخفضه في
الاونه الاخيره
تقلي بعض الياتها الى ضفه نهر النيبرو
الجنوبيه بهدف اعاده توزيع وحداتها في
المدينه ومن وسط الساحه الحمراء في موسكو
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على
اهميه اجلاء السكان المدنيين في خيرسون من
المناطق الاكثر خطوره
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك ما الذي يجري بالضبط في غير سون
محمد خيرسون هي قد تكون نقطه تحول ان كان
للجيش الاوكراني او حتى للجيش الروسي ولكن
لا نعرف النوايا المضبوطه المهمه ولكن
مؤشرات الميدان هي التي تعطي الفكره
الاساسيه يقال ان هناك ثلاث سيناريوات
ممكنه يعني القرار بالانسحاب الكامل من
هنا فكره تفجير سد نوفاكوكا والذي [__] 15
مليون متر مكعب من المياه وذلك لتغطيه
الانسحاب هذا سيناريو قد يكون بعيد جدا
السينات الثاني ان يكون هناك تراجع
وانسحاب على مراحل بعد استنزاف الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يتقدم من الشمال هذا
سيناريو اما سيناريو الثالث وهذا اعتقد
انه قد يكون ال- ال- يعني الافضل او
الاكثر همم قبولا او حدوثا هو ان يكون
هناك اخلاء المدينه تحضيرها لمعركه مدن
لمع مدن وشوارع مهمه جدا كما حدث في ماريو
بول لانه لا اعتقد ان الرئيس بوتين سيعطي
خرسون كهديه للرئيس لينسكي بعد الذي حصل
في هاركاف ربما لهذا السبب بوتين اليوم
اعلن عن ضروره ابعاد المدنيين عن هذه
المعارك لكن هناك تخبط فيما يتعلق بحضر
التجوال او عدم حضره تجوال من قبل السلطات
المحليه هناك المواليه لموسكو
اخراج المدنيين له عده ابعاد محمد هناك ما
يسمى بالسلفيه اعاده التكوين الاثني
واخذهم باتجاه الروسيه هذه احدى التغيير
الخارطه الاثنيه همم
الديموغرافيه هذا شيء الشيء الاخر هو
اتاحه المجال يعني منع التجول هو فرد نوع
من السريه لاعاده التمركز والتموضع قد
تكون همم مهمه او ليست مهمه ولكن هناك
معلومات تاتي من الجيش الاوكراني تقول ان
هناك التعزيزات لمدينه خرسان باكثر من
1000 جندي لا نعرف نوعيه هذا العسكر هل هو
من المستدعيين الجدد الاحتياط المهم من
النخبه ولكن يبدو ان هناك شيء يحضر لمدينه
خرسان اليوم ام بعد انتهاء التحضير لمعركه
قادمه بعد الشتاء بعد الربيع هذه امور
تقريبا يجب انتظار المؤشرات
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا من بيروت
صوت المعارك في اوكرانيا مازال يتردد صداه
في اروقه اي محفل دولي ففي اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه في مجموعه السبعه في المانيا
والجهه تحذير لروسيا من استخدام اسلحه
كيميائيه او بيولوجيه في الحرب وبالتزامن
مع هذا الاجتماع كان المستشار الالماني
الوفودز نفسه يزور بيجين ويبحث مع الرئيس
الصيني جيمنج سبل التاثير على روسيا
الكل يتحدث عن الحرب في اوكرانيا من مستر
غربيه المانيا الى بيتين مع اختلاف
الاجندات والحسابات والعلاقات مع موسيقى
كما جرت العالم منذ شهور على تجديد الدعم
الكيف بكل الوسائل واكثر
روسيا من اي استخدام
النووي الروسي اللي مسؤول غير مقبول واعلن
ان شاء الله
والسعاده بنيتها التحتيه الحيويه للطاقه
والمياه والدفاع عنها
اجمع داخل الاجتماعات المغلقه على الحاجه
الى تمديد مبادره البحر الاسود لتصدير
الحبوب بعد مسلسل لتعليق روسيا مشاركتها
ثم عودتها كبرت المخاوف من وفاه الاتفاق
رسميا بعد التاسعه عشر من الشهر الجاري هل
مجرى في بيجين خلال يوم واحد كفيل بتغيير
صوره رسمت على مدى شهور الحرب في اوكرانيا
ممثلا لاوروبا وليس فقط لالمانيا اجرى
المستشار اولاس محادثات مع الرئيس الصيني
ورئيس الحكومه ووزير الخارجيه
وصف الرئيس
لضيفه الوضع الدوليه
وابلغه انه ينبغي على الصين والمانيا
العمل سويا كدولتين مؤثرتين وتقديم
اسهامات للسلام والتنميه في اوقات التغير
والفوضى
قد لا تكون واشنطن مرتاحه لهذه الصور
المهم ان الشغل مقتنع بسعيه الى تنميه
التعاون الاقتصادي بين برلين وبيجين بشكل
اكبر حتى في ظل وجود تباين في وجهات النظر
بشان بعض القضايا لم يختلف في البلدان على
نقطه رفض استخدام الاسلحه النوويه في
الحرب الدائره
والقول بوضوح ان تصعيدا في الحرب على شكل
استخدام سلاح النووي تكتيكي مرفوض وانا
سعيد جدا الان لاننا توصلنا الى اتفاق
بشان هذا الموضوع على الاقل
في موسكو في عيد الوحده اكد الرئيس بلادي
مير بوتين انا مواجهه روسيا مع النظام
النازي في كيف كانت حتميه تحدث مع متطوعين
عن الصيد في القوات الاوكرانيه للمدنيين
في خرسون
الناجمه عن الاجراءات الهجوميه والهجوميه
المضاده وغيرها
الروسيه
على الجزء الغربي
الحرب باسلحتها وقممها واجتماعاتها
ومعسكراتها الخفيه والظاهره مستمره ودون
صيغه الشك حتى نهايه السنه الحاليه وبدايه
الجديده
اليوم في زياره لم يعلن عنها مسبقا وقالت
وكاله بلومبرج ان سليمان
[موسيقى]
افادت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن منصه
تويتر سرحت نحو 50 بالمئه من موظفيها في
كل انحاء العالم بحسب وثيقه الداخليه وكان
موظفون في تويتر قد تقدموا بدعوه قضائيه
تعتبر ان خطوه ملك المنصه الجديد
قانون العمل في الولايات المتحده وبينما
لم تحدد الوثيقه عدد الموظفين المانيين
بهذا الاجرام بان قرابه ثلاثه الاف و700
موظف سيتعين عليهم المغادره وهو نصف عدد
موظفين تويتر في العالم وكانت صحيفه ذكرت
ان شركات الكبرى من بينها جنرال موتورز
وفايزر واودي علقت اعلاناتها في تويتر
وينضم الى الان من دبل سيفا فايد هناسون
وهو استاذ الاعلام في جامعه فرجينيا
والخبير في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
في تويتر
ماتش ولا يهمه كثيرا الشركه ذاتها سواء
نجحت او حققت اموال او حتى التجربه
مستخدمين تويتر ستكون جيده لديه اجنده
الخاصه حول مجده الخاص ولكن هذا المسجد
الخاص
تكلفته مليارات الدولارات هذه مجازفه كبرى
يعني
ولبعض البنوك التي اقرا المال وكذلك
في السعوديه
وصندوق الاستثمار السعودي هو ثاني اكبر
مساهم في الشركه التي اصبحت خاصه
ايضا وهذا شيء سيكون جديدا من المتابعه
وسيكون لديها كثير من التاثير حول الطريقه
التي تدار
تويتر
من عدم الفهم يعني برايك لماذا لم ياخذ
بعض الوقت حتى يفهم ما يجري بالضبط في
تويتر
قراراته على على بينه
من الشعب ان نقول هو غني لدرجه
والاغنياء بهذا الشكل يفهمون انهم اغنى
الناس ولا احد يمكنه ان يقول لهم كيف
يتصرفون اذا بدلا من الاستماع الى الخبراء
ومن يعملون في تويتر والاستماع الى من هم
هم
لديه اصدقاء اغنياء وهم رجال
لكي محدودين في الحياه
ويعتقدون انهم اذكى الناس في العالم لذلك
هو من الصعب ان يساء الى نفسه ويسائله حد
عن خطته طالما هو معجب
بثروته وبذكائه هل تعتقد بانه مستعد لدفع
تعويضات لكل هؤلاء لانهم هؤلاء رفعوا
القضايا
ويبدو ان الطرد لم يحترم همم قوانين
الولايات المتحده
نعم هذا جدير بالاعتمام يبدو لقد
طرد جميعها هؤلاء
العاملين وهمم بدون اساسا قانوني وكلها
هؤلاء الموظفين المئات منهم يمكنهما ان
يتقدموا بشكاوه وهو فعاله بعضهم للحصول
على تعويضات حسب القانون اذا قد يجد نفسه
يخسر الكثير من الاموال لو انه كان يمكن
لو انتظر بدعه اسابيع كان يمكنه ان ينتظر
بدعه اسابيع كما قلنا ويرا كيف تسير
الامور ويتحدث الى
من يعملون وبدنا من ذلك يتصرف بهذا الجنون
بهذه السرعه
وهو يتصرف بنوعا من الكبرياء
وكانه
وياخذ كل المجازفات ولا يهمه من عواقبها
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم الرئيسي ان
من يساهم في ما وصفها باعمال الشغب في
بلاده عندما ينفذ استراتيجيه الولايات
المتحده واعداء الثوره حسب تعبيره وشدد
رئيسي في كلمه الله بمناسبه ذكر اقتحام
السفاره الامريكيه في طهران على ان بلاده
لن تخضع للغرب
السودان
في ذكرى اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه بدايه
الثوره الايرانيه او ما يعرف في ايران
بيوم الطالب
في هذا الوقت لتظهر قوه شعبيه في وقت
تواجه في احتياجات مناوعه في مناطق مختلفه
من ايران
بالوقوف وراء الاحداث الاخيره في ايران
فكان لهم النصيب الاكبر من شعارات ومواقف
ومنددته بسياساتهم ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
اي شخص اليوم اينما كان في البلاد اذا كان
داعما للفوضى واعمال الشغب فانه يخدم
استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده والاعداء واي
شخص يدعو للهدوء والاستقرار فهو يدعم
استراتيجيه الثوره الاسلاميه والشعب
الايراني لن يخضع للغربه وسيبقى صامدا
امام مخططاتهم ومؤامراتهم
[تصفيق]
تحضروا ذكر اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه
ويحضر معها دور الطلبه فهم من اقتحموها
عام
1979 وبشعاره ثوريه وقتها تحرك لحمايه ما
يرونه تهديدا امريكيا للثوره الصاعده
تحرك زمن الثوره ومن الجامعه التي خرج
منها من اقتحم السفاره الامريكيه يرتفع
اليوم صوت طلابي بشعارات اخرى تجاوزت
مطالب الاصلاح الى التغيير وهو الصوت الذي
تردد اصداه كذلك خارج الصور الجامعه بعد
وفاه الفتاه مهس امن في مخفر الشرطه
في تخفيف احتجاجات الناس في الشارع كون
الحركه الطلابيه ستكون ممثلا للشعب في
الدفاع عن مطالبه واذا تعاملت الحكومه
بشفافيه مع القطاع الطلابي فان هذا سيسهم
في تراجع الاحتجاجات
تتارجح المواقف هنا في طهران حكومه تقول
انها ترفض الشغب ولا مشكله لديها مع
الاحتجاجات طالما كانت علميه ومحتاجون
يريدون الخروج من الوضع الاجتماعي الحالي
وما بينهما تتعالى اصوات تؤكد ان حل كل
مشكله يتم بالحوار
استاذ عسلقه الايرانيه الى السيطره على
الاوضاع بعد الاحتجاجات فهي تبحث عن
استقرار داخلي وترى نفسها امام تحديات
اقليميه ودوليه متصاعده وهناك من يرى ان
ترك المشاكل الداخليه دون حل قد يفقد
الدوله استقرارا هي في امس الحاجه اليه في
هذه المرحله
الجزيره طهران
ثلاث لولوه الخاطر والمساعده وزير
الخارجيه القطريه للجزيره ان الفعاليات
المتعلقه بحمايه الصحفيين مهمه لضمان
استمرار التذكير بالاستهداف الذي يتعرضون
له واقدار جميع المسؤولين عن ذلك للمساعده
واضافه الخاتم في ختام اجتماعات الذكر
العشاء العاشره لميثاق حمايه الصحفيين
المنظم من قبل اليونسكو وزاره الخارجيه
النمساويه في فينا اضافت ان رحيل الزميله
شيرين ابو عاقله احدث ما وصفتها بالهزه
الكبيره التي لم نهدها من قبل لتحريك
المياه كده
الضجه التي احدثها ذلك الرحيل الكبير
للمناضل الكبيره والصحفيه الكبيره شيرين
ابو عقله لا شك انه احدث هزه لم نهدها من
قبل ان شاء الله هذه هي الهزه التي تحرك
المياه الراكده للافضل
واملنا في الله سبحانه وتعالى ايضا كبير
وسنضل من ناحيتنا ونتمنى من الجميع ان
يبقوا هذه الذكرى حيه ليس فقط ذكر شيرين
وهي ذكرى مهمه جدا ومؤلمه ولكن ايضا ذكره
كثير من الصحفيين همم ولكم في قناه
الجزيره ربما يعني معرفه بهذا الامر من
ضمن الاشياء التي لابد من التذكير بها هو
الناشرين واحد من اكثر من 45 صحفي فلسطيني
قتلوا على يد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
انا الجيش الكوريه الجنوبيه نشر 80 مقاتله
ردا على اجراء على اجراء مماثل من قبل
كوريا الشماليه وكانت سول قد اعلنت في وقت
سابقا رصد تحركي نحوي 180 طائره حربيه
كوريه شماليه من المجال الجويه
مع مناورات جويه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه هي الكبرى في تاريخ
العلاقه بين البلدين
تصعيد متبادل بين شطرين شبه الجزيره
الكوريه على واقع مناورات العاصفه اليقظه
التي تنخرط فيها كوريا الجنوبيه مع
الولايات المتحده تتواصلوا مشاهد استعراض
القوه بين الكوريتين المناورات التي تقررت
تمديدها الى السبت بسبب تصاعد التوتر هي
الكبرى في تاريخ العلاقات بين واشنطن التي
اعلنت انها تشارك بنحو 240 طائره حجم
المناورات دفع المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الكوريه الشماليه لدعوه واشنطن لوقتها
باعتبارها استفزازيه هو الاستفزاز
المتبادل اذا كما ان المناورات تستفز
الشطر الشمالي فللجنوب ايضا ما يستفزه
ويرقه يقول كوريا الجنوبيه انها نشرت 80
مقاتله بعضها من طراز اف 35 اي ردا على ما
قالت انها رصدته من تحليق نحو 180 طائره
حربيه حوريه شماليه شمال الحدود العسكريه
على مدى اربع ساعات كما اتهمت السلول ليس
الكوريه الشماليه باطلاق نحو 80 قذيفه
مدفعيه على المنطقه الحدوديه البحريه بين
البلدين الهاجس الاكبر لكوريا الجنوبيه
وحلفائها ما اكدته السل من النجاره الشمال
اطلقت الخميس صاروخا باليستيا عابرا
للقارات قطع نحو 760 كلم على ارتفاع
1920 كيلو مترا تقريبا رجحت هيئه الاركان
الكوريه الجنوبيه فشل العمليه لكن كوريا
الشماليه لا تتوقف عن تجارب الاطلاق تلك
التي بلغت مستوى قياسيا خلال العام الجاري
تقرا خطواته بيونغيانغ باعتبارها
استفزازات متكرره تستوجب الرد بتدبيره هذا
ما اكده وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
خلال لقائه بواشنطن نظيره الكوريه الجنوبي
لجون قال اوستن ان اي هجوم النووي على
بلاده او حلفائها وشركائها سيتسبب في
نهايه نظام كيم جون
مونامور
امريكيا فقط بل جاء في بيان لمجموعه السبع
ان اي تجربه نوويه كوريه شماليه او اي عمل
طائش يجب ان يواجه برد دولي سريع وموحد
وقوي
حافه الانفجار التي تصل اليها تلك
التهديدات تقابلها مساعي تهدئه سياسيه
فواشنطن وفق تصريحات مسؤول رفيع بها
لرويترز ترغب في ان تستخدم الصين وروسيا
نفوذهما لاقناع كوريا الشماليه بعدم
استئناف تجارب قنبله النوويه بل ساعه
الولايات المتحده للتواصل مع كوريا
الشماليه عبر قنوات خاصه ومن خلال اطراف
ثالثه وفي الوقت نفسه تستكمل ترتيبات لعقد
قمه بين قاده الولايات المتحده واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه منتصف الشهر الجاري ترفض
الولايات المتحده ان يتعامل المجتمع
الدولي مع كوريا الشماليه باعتبارها قوه
نوويه ولتحقيق ذلك تراوح بين خيارين
الحراك السياسي والتلويح بالقوه العسكريه
مستثمره تحالفاتها مع جيران بيونج
الاقربين
[موسيقى]
سيده ساعات الاخيره حلقه جديده من ارتفاع
منسوب التوتر في شبه جزيره الكوريه نتحدث
عن سجل ميداني وكلامي ايضا تضمن تبادلا
للالتهابات اليوم الجمعه اعلن الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي
80 مقاتله شبح بعضها من طراز اف 35 اي على
طول منطقه الحدود
ردا على رصد الجيش الكوري الجنوبي اكثر من
80 قذيفه مدفعيه اطلقت في البحر من قبل
كوريا الشماليه رئاسه الاركان في سوريا
اعتبرت ان اطلاق القذائف يشكل انتهاكا
واضحا لاتفاق عام 2018 بين الكوريتين
والذي انشا المناطق العازله بهدف الحد من
التوتر
كما رصد الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه اليوم ايضا
تحرك نحو 180 طائره حربيه كوريه شماليه تم
التعبئتها في المجال الجوي ليبيونغ
وقالت سول ان الطائرات حلقت على مختلف
الاجواء في الجزء الشمالي من خط العمل
التكتيكيكي ومياه الشرق والغرب من شبه
جزيره الكوريه والذي رسم على مسافه تصل
الى 20 كيلومترا شمال خط الترسيم العسكري
على الحدود
تطورات الساعات الاخيره جاءت في عقاب بيان
المشترك لوزيري الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه
والامريكي اشار الى الاتفاق على اجراءات
جديده لاظهار التصميم وقدرات التحالف
بينهما
تحرك سلو واشنطن لم يقتصر على البيان
بطبيعه الحال ومنذ يوم الاثنين تجري كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده واحدا من اكبر
التدريبات الجويه بين الجانبين على
الاطلاق
يشمل هذا التدريب المشترك المقرر ان يستمر
حتى يوم غدا السبت تنفيذ مئات الطائرات
الحربيه الكوريه الجنوبيه والامريكيه
ومنها مقاتلات اف 35 محاكاه لمهام على
مدار الساعه
يوم الاربعاء وصفت اوصفت بيونديانغ
التدريبات التي سميت العاصفه اليقظه بانها
استفزازيه وعدائيه مهدده سول و واشنطن
بدفع اكبر ثمن في التاريخ
بعد التهديد بساعات اطلقت كوريا الشماليه
23 صاروخا وهو رقم قياسي لعمليات الاطلاق
في يوم واحد من بينها صاروخ سقط قباله
سواحل كوريا الجنوبيه لاول مره
كما اطلقت كوريا الشماليه عده صواريخ امس
الخميس بما في ذلك تجربه فاشله على الارجح
بصاروخ بالستي عابر للقارات
نظم الينا الان من روما الدكتور ماتيو
ديان الخبير في الشؤون الاسيويه اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدان
ما خطوره هذا التوتر بين الكوريتين هذه
المره
كبير
راينا يوم الاربعاء
بالامس يوم الخميس
في الوصول الى غايته
ومع ذلك فهذه بوادر على ان كوريا الشماليه
مصممه على تحقيق تطور في صواريخها
البرستيه والمحللون يقولون انها تنوي
تجربه صاروخ نوويه والقيام بالتجربه
النوويه اخرى
انه هجومي اااه يوقفوا
مرحله
معين
وهناك النيه واضحه في زياده القدرات
العسكريه ولاجبار الجنوبيه واا الولايات
المتحده على الاستماع اليها
اهدافها هو العوده الى المفاوضات وان يكون
لها صفه الاعتراف بكونها قوه
نوويه وكذلك تخفيف ال عقوبات
لانها معزوله خاصه
خلال الجائحه والعقوبات التي فرضتها
الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها وهي تضر تلحق ضررا كبيرا
بالاقتصاد الكوري وهي تحاول ان تستخدم هذه
التجارب
من اجل حاله الدبلوماسيه الوضع لا يتراجع
الان
هو هناك همم تصرفات غير مسبوقه
والامر
[موسيقى]
وهذا الرئيس ليس منفتحا الكوري الشمالي
كما كان السابق
يحاول ان يكون شديدا
والشيء نفسه ويمكن ان نقوله عن الولايات
المتحده
تحديدا السيد الديان هل هل ترى واشنطن هذه
المره اكثر انخراطا في هذه المواجهه
الشماليه الجنوبيه في كوريا
الناس اقل من المقارنه مع الماضي
ان يحصل يحرز التقدم الكبير
الرئيس
متفائلا كثيرا من هذه المقاربه
الهدف الرئيسي هو
التنافس مع
الصين ولذلك فان افضل طريقه هي ان يكون
هناك تنسيق مع حلفاء الاقليميين كوريا
الجنوبيه
واليابان لذلك سيكون الامر اكثر تعقيدا
لتحقيق الهدفين في الوقت نفسه تعزيز
التحالف
والتفاوض مع كوريا الشماليه لذلك في المدى
القصير على الاقل فان الاولويه
شكرا لك ومعذره على المقاطعه
[موسيقى]
يعود الى افريقيا
منذ عام 1958
عندما تصدر في بلد شعار ثورته الحريه
المساواه والاخوه دمت بخير
[موسيقى]